i can play without losing and
yeah i think prague you can tell on his
body language he wants liam to resign
now he knows he's winning yeah the black
king and knight just can't stand that
ground no matter which piece moves the
white king or rook will come towards
that black pawn and win it and we do see
the other players coming back to the
oslo esports arena magnus cross and
underneath geary just started game three
we're going to jump into that when this
one finishes probably with a win
for the amazing pragmata
it's getting close even uh if the clocks
are ticking yeah liam there just taking
a sip of his water you can tell on
liam's body language as well he knows
it's over he knows it's hopeless for
black he defended like a lie in there
but not quite enough
and uh maybe he'll let his clock run out
maybe he'll just take this extra 45
seconds to kind of breathe get over this
defeat but yeah
pretty depressing isn't it because he
was clearly losing and then he was just
losing and then he was kind of like okay
you know and he's got he got his spirits
up but okay it's over now yeah and then
he lost and then he lost yeah